Today is google developer program that response to that raw wood
Today I will tell you about the latest web views
The implementation of web views from android 4.4 kitkat has been completely revamped
It is based on chromium
Significant improvements in web standards compliance and performance
The implementation of the live has changed significantly, but the app is basically web view as before
You can use
However, there are some points to be noted and additional functions that are useful for development.
To do
Introduce the relationship between arch set and web view
The code you're looking at is just an example, but in the background thread launched
Working on web views web views as well as other views
It should also be done from the main thread originally, but until now android
Then, such a code was working for the time being
Such code will stop working from android 4.4
Eg using the run on ui thread method of the activity class
Make sure to handle the web view from the main thread
Run in javascript background from java side in relation to this
It became easy to receive the result
For example, the code to be executed on the first argument of the 8th javascript method
Argument callback
Or pass null if you do not need the results
There are also changes in the handling of custom urls
If you click a link in html to display in web view
Override url loading may not be called
As above, if you specify just a string as a link destination, load data or
load data with base url without specifying base url
When html is loaded, overriding url loading is
Not called
Please use some custom schema as below
The code you see is an example of what happens when a link is clicked
Parse and handle url when passed url matching your own schema
Remote debugging of web views is now possible
Here, it is assumed that the development environment of android has been set up
We will show you how to set up remote debugging
To debug web views remotely extension to the latest chrome
Must be installed
Please install the extension from the url you see
It is necessary for the app side to handle it. To make web views debuggable
Invoke backing method-blue method on set web content
In the code you see, drinking with android 4.4 or later introduced remote debugging
Is to activate the bag
I want to match the web view debug enable setting with the app's own debug enable setting
If
As you can see it can be achieved by using build config. Debug
Let's look at the steps to actually do remote debugging
I installed earlier to open the device list
Select View Inspection Month from the menu of the chrome extension
please
When you open a list of devices, you can debug them running on each device
The web view is displayed in a list
As it shows where each web view is displayed on the screen
Click Inspect next to the web view you want to debug
As you can see, the debug screen is a regular crew chrome developer
same as tool
For example, when you move the cursor to html like chrome is remote
Highlights elements in real time on debug
How is it? By all means android 4.4 greatly evolved web view
Please try to make an application using Thank you for watching